hello my name is Steven Garvin I'm a
professor of physics and professor of
Applied Physics at Yale University and a
member of the Yale quantum Institute I'm
going to talk to you today about quantum
computing about circuit QED which is the
primary architecture for building a
quantum computer using an all-electronic
system of superconducting quantum bits
it was developed here at Yale with my
colleagues Michele Devery and Rob
schulhoff and I'm going to introduce you
to that topic and then talk about
quantum error correction how you can try
to do nearly perfect calculations on a
quantum computer built from imperfect
parts the first quantum revolution was
in the first half of the 20th century it
brought us the transistor the laser the
atomic clock the global positioning
system and the inventors of quantum
mechanics didn't were doing basic
research they did not foresee these
remarkable quantum devices the inventors
of these quantum devices did not foresee
their amazing applications that brought
us the technological revolution of the
20th century that the first makers of
individual handmade transistors could
not imagine integrated circuits and the
fact that today in the world
approximately 60 trillion transistors
are produced every second these quantum
devices however from the 20th century do
not actually take advantage of the full
power of quantum mechanics
there's now in the 21st century a second
quantum revolution which is building
devices to take full advantage of the
full power of quantum mechanics and one
of the powers has to do with computing
processing information in completely new
ways quantum computers use the principle
of superposition that a quantum bit or
qubit can exist in in an infinite number
of states that are intermediate between
0 and 1 there is some very crude sense
in which quantum bits can be both 0 and
1 at the same time a more subtle concept
is that of entanglement an entanglement
is another kind of superposition that
allows there to be non classical
extra-strong correlations amongst
different bits that are widely separated
from each other something that I'm
stained objected to strongly because he
understood the implications of this new
quantum theory he called it spooky
action at a distance and did not like it
these two effects however give us a kind
of quantum parallelism that lets a
quantum computer do many calculations in
parallel and at a rate which is
impossible on any conventional computer
the irony is that as part of a daily
routine engineering calibration test of
our quantum computers we carry out these
spooky operations that Einstein felt had
to be impossible and we use those to
verify that our quantum computer really
is a quantum computer and not a
classical computer so now that you are
experts on quantum computing here's a
quiz but
worry I'm going to give you the answers
the first question in the quiz is is
quantum information carried by waves or
particles and the answer of course is
yes second question is quantum
information analog or digital and again
the answer is yes quantum information
can be stored in a continuous analog
fashion in intermediate superpositions
between 0 and 1 and yet when we measure
the quantum bit we always get the result
0 or 1 so now let's talk about circuit
quantum electrodynamics the the idea of
quantum electrical circuits quantum
integrated chips the experiments I'm
going to talk about are carried out by
my colleagues Michelle Duggar a Luigi
friends erm show off and there are many
graduate students and postdocs and both
the theory and experiment side that have
contributed to the ideas that I'm going
to tell you about so what is quantum
electrodynamics that's the study of
atoms and electrons coupled to photons
to particles of light and the fact that
the electromagnetic field is quantized
means that it has zero point
fluctuations or vacuum fluctuations
quantum uncertainty and how big the
electric and magnetic fields are in the
VAT even in a vacuum when there's no
light supposedly and these fluctuations
modify the spectrum of atoms of the
energy levels of atoms so for example if
I have a hydrogen atom the first thing
you learn is there are certain quantized
energy levels which are stationary
States that live forever but if you look
more closely if you include the fact
that this atom is sitting in the
electromagnetic vacuum which has
fluctuating those fluctuations will
destabilized the two-piece state and
caused the electron to fall down to the
ground state the 1s state irreversibly
by spontaneously emitting a photon into
the vacuum in a time typical time of
about 1.6 nanoseconds other effects of
vacuum fluctuations in which an electron
can virtually emit and then quickly
reabsorb a photon leads to an effect
called the Lamb shift which causes the
2s and 2p states to not quite be at
exactly the same energy the goal of
cavity quantum electrodynamics is to
modify the available photon States by
for example trapping atoms between two
highly reflecting mirrors that reflect
optical light that can interact with the
atoms and make instead of a continuous
range of photon frequencies available to
the atom only discrete allowed
resonances based on the distance between
the two mirrors in the cavity I'm going
to talk to you about microwave cavity
QED or in circuit quantum
electrodynamics in which we have some
sort of superconducting box or other
resonator in an electrical circuit which
completely surrounds a region and can
trap microwave photons inside so it's
like having almost perfectly reflecting
mirrors completely surrounding an
artificial atom which I'll tell you
about and unlike the optical QED cavity
QED case the atom when it tries to emit
a photon in any direction it's always
reflected back and is not able to escape
and as a result of that the lifetime
force Ponte
mission of the excited state of our
artificial atom can be enhanced by a
factor of a thousand
if the cavity does not have a resonance
frequency that matches that of the atom
and this enhancement of the lifetime is
very very helpful in trying to store and
manipulate quantum information in
superposition states of our artificial
atoms so in circuit QED which is an
analogue of cavity QED as I said the
microwave photons are inside
superconducting circuits and are we
don't use real atoms we use artificial
atoms Josephson Junction quantum bits or
qubits and these artificial atoms are
very large and couple very strongly to
photons and give us the ability to do
what's called nonlinear quantum optics
in a completely new regime of individual
photons so here you see a cartoon of a
hydrogen atom obviously not to scale the
diameter of the boar orbit is about 10
to the minus 10 meters the frequency of
transition between the 1s and 2p state
that I talked about is about two and a
half
pedda Hertz 10 to the 15 Hertz the
lifetime of the excited state before it
spontaneously decays as I mentioned
about 1.6 nanoseconds the cue of this
oscillation the quality factor which is
the product of the frequency and the
lifetime is about four million and the
transition dipole moment the ability of
this atom to couple to electromagnetic
fields because there is a charge moving
around is captured by this so-called
dipole moment which is about 1/2 by or
about one electron charge times the Bohr
radius of this
but let's compare this to an artificial
atom made of superconducting aluminum
evaporated on an insulating substrate
and containing a joke
Josephson Junction which I'll explain
momentarily the size of this atom is
about a millimeter it's seven orders of
magnitude larger than this atom it has a
transition frequency six orders of
magnitude smaller about seven gigahertz
which is in the domain of cell phone
signals microwave signals a lifetime of
the excited state is about 300
microseconds much longer than the
hydrogen atom but the Q the quality
factor is about the same two million but
what's really different is the
transition dipole moment which is sort
of a measure of how much charge is
moving over what distance that's several
pairs of electrons moving a millimeter
it's about 30 million times larger than
for the hydrogen atom and this enormous
transition dipole moment allows us to do
quantum mechanics and quantum
electrodynamics in a completely new
regime so this object this jozin
Junction object can be an artificial
atom it can be viewed as a quantum bit
or qubit it has to be operated near
absolute zero so that the material the
metal is superconducting but you can
build superconducting integrated
circuits out of this by the same
technology that's used to make
semiconducting integrated circuits in
today's classical computers the
transistor of quantum computing the
heart of our artificial atom is this
thing called the Josephson Junction
which I mentioned before it consists of
two pieces of aluminum which are
superconducting separated by a very
Phin one nanometer thick insulating
layer of aluminum oxide here you see an
electron micrograph of it it's about two
thousand items wide and two thousand
atoms high and a few atoms thick this
object provides the anharmonic energy
structure of an LC oscillator it acts
like the artificial atom has a capacitor
and it has some nonlinear inductance
caused by this Joe's injunction which
allows pairs so-called Cooper pairs of
electrons in the superconductor to
tunnel through this thin barrier and
slosh back and forth between the two
capacitor plates on this artificial atom
and it acts like an inductor whose
inductance is not constant but varies
with how much current is flowing in the
circuit and makes this into an an
harmonic oscillator the the potential
seen by this oscillator is a cosine of a
certain angle a certain phase difference
of the superconducting order parameter
across the two sides of the junction
here's a different design the so-called
transman qubit this is like an
artificial atom with atomic number one
trillion it has ten to the twelve mobile
electrons in these aluminium films
evaporated on this insulating substrate
it's about a it's like an antenna a
millimeter long and the two halves of
the antenna are connected by this
Josephson tunnel Junction the soup you
might think if I had an atom with atomic
number 10 to the 12 it would be
impossible to solve for the spectrum of
that atom it would be impossibly complex
but superconductivity gaps out all of
the single particle
excitation zin the electron gas in the
aluminum and the only low energy
excitations are pairs of electrons
sloshing back and forth between the two
antennae pads and so the quantized
energy levels of this object are simply
those of an an harmonic oscillator the
ground to first excited state transition
is at perhaps five gigahertz and the
first excited - second excited
transition is at perhaps four point nine
gigahertz slightly lower because the
cosine potential is softer than the
parabola of a harmonic oscillator and so
it has negative and harmonicity the
quality factor of this is I mentioned
about the same as a hydrogen 1s 2p but
the enormous transition dipole moment
caused by the charges moving back and
forth a millimeter means that this atom
which has its own antenna built in can
talk very very strongly couple very
strongly to microwave photons in a
cavity which is surrounding this
artificial atom so this is the the
artificial atom in our circuit quantum
electrodynamics what can we do with this
well here is an example here is a
Hamiltonian you don't need to understand
the details but there's a mode in the
cavity which is a harmonic oscillator it
has an energy which is an integer times
Planck's constant times the frequency of
the resonator this just counts the
number of photons in the microwave
cavity we can approximate the two-level
atom at the sorry the an harmonic
oscillator as a two-level atom and
described that mathematically as a
pseudo spin 1/2 with spin down being the
ground state spin up being the excited
state and because the other transition
frequencies are different due to the
anharmonicity we can ignore them in a
certain approximate
and when the atom in the cavity have
different transition frequencies then
the net effect is you are in what's
called the dispersive regime and the
effective dipole coupling enters in
second order and produces this term
which causes the transition frequency of
the atom to shift by a number Chi each
time you add one more photon to the
cavity so here you see the spectrum of
the cavity I'm sorry of the atom we
shine microwaves on the atom and see
what frequency causes it to transition
from the ground to excited state and we
see a series of Peaks corresponding to
how many photons are in the cavity 0 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8
microwave photons in the cavity chi is
negative so the frequency goes down
there's a quantized light shift
associated with how many photons are in
the cavity so what you should learn from
the fact that there are discrete Peaks
here is that microwaves despite their
name are particles they are photons
they're just as good photons as the
optical photons that cause the chemical
reactions in your eye to let you see
even though they have a hundred thousand
or million times less energy there are
still particles with quantized lumps of
energy and the fact that you now can
detect these individual microwave
photons is giving us new ways to search
for certain types of dark matter called
accion particles and so one of the
applications of all this is not simply
to produce a new kind of quantum
computer but also to do quantum sensing
to detect extremely weak signals of
interest in cosmology and astrophysics
so with this Hamiltonian with this
strong coupling between the atom and the
cavity we can control the state of both
we can apply drive signals to the sorry
to the cavity shown here we can apply
drive signals to this transman two-level
system here and produce any quantum
state of the combined system for example
suppose we wanted to do something that
would be considered extremely difficult
in ordinary quantum optics take an empty
cavity with zero photons and put exactly
six photons into that cavity that would
be extremely difficult with ordinary
optics but is relatively easy here so
here you see a plot of some control
signals that have been pre computed that
we apply to the trans month and another
control signal that we apply to the
cavity and here is a graph with where
the color scale shows you the
probability that there are n photons in
the cavity as a function of time and you
see you start at zero it rises up it
dips down it kind of splits into two
parts and then at the last second or the
last nanosecond 500 nanoseconds into the
sequence boom all of the probability
lands on N equals six there are now
exactly six photons in the cavity and
here you see a plot called the Vigna
function which verifies for us that we
are in the N equals six state so you can
think of this Vigna function as a kind
of quasi probability distribution in the
phase space of the quantum oscillator so
think of this axis as the coordinate of
the electromagnetic oscillator
perhaps the
electric field measured at the center of
the cavity would be the coordinate and
this axis is the momentum or the
magnetic field in the electromagnetic
oscillator and you see this beautiful
bull's eye pattern which is completely
circularly symmetric and changes color
the colors indicate the sign of the
Vigna function so it's not a probability
distribution it's a quasi-probability
distribution like a quantum amplitude
because it can be both positive and
negative the fact that it's completely
circularly symmetric means that we don't
know the phase of the oscillation of the
cavity and that's just the number phase
uncertainty relation we know that the
number of photons is exactly 6 so we
cannot assign a phase to that it's a
superposition of all possible phases
here's another example we can create
Schrodinger cat state we can make an
oscillator be displaced to the right and
to the left to be in two coordinates at
the two different places at the same
time and here you see the Vigna function
for that case you see this blob on the
Left represents the coherent state minus
alpha we've displaced the oscillator to
the left this blob represents the
coherent state plus alpha the oscillator
is displaced to the right you see that
it's a blob not a point as it would be
classically and that's vacuum noise
that's the fact that the position of the
oscillator and the momentum do not
commute and so it's impossible to know
both of them precisely simultaneously
equivalently this is the vacuum noise
the electromagnetic noise of the vacuum
right before your very eyes in the
middle you see what we call the whiskers
of the cat
these very rapid sine oscillations of
the Vigna function and they can be used
for quantum sensing if you displace the
oscillator very very slightly in the
momentum direction you get a very strong
change in that signal even though the
displacement is much smaller than the
zero point uncertainty in the momentum
furthermore the fact that the central
fringe is the same color as the blobs
tells us that we have an even cat a plus
sign in the superposition of being here
and being here and not a random mixture
so not an incoherent mixture a true
Schrodinger cat with a coherent
superposition with a definite sign
between coherent displacement to the
left and to the right just to give you
some icing on the cake here is a kind of
Schrodinger cat living in thirty five
places at once this is an amazing recent
experiment from my colleague Michelle
Deborah in which he has made a so-called
goddess Minh cat Ioffe press coal state
which is very powerful for quantum error
correction and you see these blobs which
are actually squeezed now they're
smaller than the uncertainty in the
previous slide and the cat is in 35
different places in phase space at the
same time so that just demonstrates for
you the level of quantum control that we
have over these quantum states okay so
now that's the the hardware the
background now I want to talk to you
about the quantum error correction
problem how do I correct errors in a
quantum computer that has imperfect
parts so here there is the problem in a
nutshell I'm going to give you an
unknown quantum state if you were to
measure
it will collapse it will change randomly
due to this back action resulting from
your measurement that's a problem
because if this unknown state develops
an error I want you to fix it it seems
impossible but miraculously it can be
done the fact that in principle quantum
error correction is possible is to me
much more profound and amazing than the
fact that you can do quantum computation
in principle with a perfect device you
can now even do it with real devices
that are imperfect it's still extremely
challenging but I will show you
experimental progress that we are now
able to do this at some level so how
does quantum error correction work how
can you get around the fact that when
you examine a quantum object you change
it so what you need to do is store the
quantum information not in one physical
qubit but in a logical qubit consisting
of many physical qubits in this example
there are nine and you store the quantum
information the superposition of ground
and excited state in not in one physical
object but in these spread out in some
non-local non classical spooky action at
a distance kind of correlations among
all of these qubits and the non locality
of putting the information in there is
very important because it you need for
it to be true that no single physical
qubit can know the state of the logical
qubit of the information you're trying
to store because if that one qubit
develops an error or is measured by the
environment which is what decoherence is
then you do not want the environment to
learn the state of the logical qubit and
collapse its state so you need to
the information from the environment but
then you need a Maxwell demon to correct
those errors when they occur and the
Maxwell demon which is itself made of
imperfect parts has to be so fast and so
accurate that it can make certain clever
measurements which do not tell it the
state of the logical qubit but do tell
it what errors may have occurred and on
which of the nine physical qubits the
error occurred so that it can be
corrected and the entropy so to speak
pumped into a cold bath to keep this
logical state pure well there's a big
problem right off the bat that when you
have n physical qubits the error rate
has suddenly become n times worse
because each one of the physical qubits
can have independent errors so every
quantum error correction protocol starts
by taking a giant step backward and
making the error rate worse then you
have to turn on a very clever Maxwell
demon that is so fast and so efficient
it's so accurate and doesn't introduce
errors of its own that will overcome
this factor of N and get you back to the
break-even point where the quantum
information lives as long as if it had
been in one of the single physical
qubits and hopefully even better than
that you want to be much longer lifetime
than just reaching the break-even point
so it turns out that all previous
attempts to overcome this factor of N
and reach the break-even point of
quantum error correction have actually
failed and the reason is that the
Maxwell demon has to figure out all the
different errors that could have
occurred a bit flip a phase slip a
combination of both and which of the N
physical qubits suffered that error so
it has to make
many many clever measurements of so
called error syndromes which tell it
about what errors may have occurred but
do not tell it about the logical state
in which the error occurred so that's
quite complex and difficult it's been
attempted it's sort of works but it
never actually makes things better by
overcoming that factor of n it always
makes things worse so we want to try a
different idea which is not to use
material objects as quantum bits not
those artificial atoms that I showed you
but use microwave photon States stored
in high quality factor superconducting
resonators as our logical qubit and so
to compare let's just consider the case
of three physical qubits just to keep it
simple each is a two-level artificial
atom it has a total of eight states in
the combination of three the states can
be represented by the binary numbers 0 0
0 through 1 1 1 so there are 8 numbers
there and each of those 8 quantum states
can have some quantum amplitude in the
in the entangled correlated state of the
logical qubit instead of that which is
complicated because again there are many
errors that can occur and we have to
figure out which physical qubit had the
error instead of that let's think of
putting microwave photons inside a
cavity and there can be zero photons 1 2
3 4 5 6 or 7 so there's a total of eight
states we'll consider and they can have
exactly the same quantum amplitudes as
are stored in these three physical
qubits and it's a continuous variable
system it's described by some wave
functions I of X is just a harmonic
oscillator X is the coordinate of the
oscillator but in that continuous
variable system
we have a discrete basis of photon
number States and we can store exactly
the same information but it's on one
physical object a cavity containing
photons and that's simplification using
a single object that has many states in
its Silbert space instead of many
objects with only two in each of their
states is the simplification so why why
is that an improvement well each this
harmonic oscillator has one mode and
it's weakly damped very very weakly
damped it's a high q-- oscillator and it
has only one kind of error it can decay
by losing a photon and you don't need to
know which of the the modes or which of
the physical qubits lost of the energy
it's just one single mode with one
possible error so if we could think of a
thing to measure that would detect that
error we only have to measure that one
thing and it turns out for us again
something that's very difficult to
measure in ordinary quantum optics but
easy in circuit QED is the photon number
parity is the photon number even or odd
and if I see the photon number change
from even to odd I know that I have lost
a photon an error has occurred and I
need to correct it so here is the
simplest so-called boson ik code or
continuous variable quantum error
correction code that I know of which we
developed a few years ago here yeah this
is the binomial code or the Khitan code
the it's a whole family of codes but the
simplest version is the following the
zero logical state is a coherent
superposition of zero photons in the
resonator plus four photons in the
resonator the one logical state is two
photons in the resonator so it's very
simple if I should lose a
which happens when the lowering operator
a get supplied to the state then 0
logical becomes has now three photons in
the state and one logical in the error
state has one Photon
and this is very efficient you uses only
five photon states or log to five bits
it uses fewer states than the
corresponding discrete variable error
correcting codes because it's has fewer
errors and the recovery that I want to
apply when I know that the parity has
jumped oh I should emphasize that these
two code words are both eigenstates of
parity they're both even photon numbers
and the error words have odd photon
numbers so when I'd see the parity jump
I have to apply unitary operation that
map's 3 back to 0 plus 4 and 1 back to 2
well that's a those are non-trivial
tricky operations that would be very
difficult in ordinary quantum optics but
turn out to be relatively easy with our
universal control in circuit QED so I
won't go into the details but here are
some experimental results from the Luo
Yin Sun group in changhua doing quantum
error correction on this code and
improving the lifetime by applying the
error correction and reaching 92% of the
break-even point so almost reaching
break-even and the first code and so far
the only code which is actually exceeded
breakeven and was done slightly before
that experiment was done here at Yale in
the group of my colleague Rob Scholl
cough and it used a superposition of two
different Schrodinger cat States
remember the Schrodinger cat state let's
say for the 0 logical is oscillator
displaced to the left
we proposed with oscilator displaced to
the right one logical is the oscillator
displaced in positive momentum
superposed with displacement to negative
momentum and the Vigna functions of
those two codewords are shown here and
you can produce with our universal
control arbitrary superpositions of
those states and the properties of these
states are very favorable for quantum
error correction and by encoding the
information in these logical photon
States and applying the error correction
operation
the show-off group for the first time in
any technology finally exceeded the
break-even point only about 10% but did
so and then if you it turns out that
this system will raise its hand when
there's an error it will Harold errors
and in 20% of the cases it raises his
hand and says something went wrong
if you post select only on the 80% of
the data where that didn't happen then
you reached 1.75 times break even so
this is still not as good as we want to
do but it's the first time that
breakeven has been robustly reached so
we have a great deal a great staircase
to climb towards our ultimate goal of
fault-tolerant quantum computation and
you can see a series of steps here we're
somewhere in the middle we've done we've
created a logical memory with a slightly
longer lifetime than the individual
physical parts through quantum error
correction we've done operations on
single logical qubits we've done
entangling gates on pairs of logical
qubits but we're still a long way from
error correction producing dramatic
enhancement
a lifetime and being able to do that at
large-scale to produce a full
fault-tolerant quantum computation but
we feel like we're making great progress
and doing lots of interesting physics
along the way so here thank you very
much for listening and here are some
references to the experiment and
theoretical papers thank you very much